Our smartphones are constantly collecting data
about us.
From the language we use in our texts and social media
posts, to what we like to watch and listen to.
Our data can alert us to unhealthy habits— lack of sleep,
too few steps, too much screen time.
Now, some researchers want to use these data
to predict when someone might attempt suicide.
For decades, scientists have  tried to suss out the risk
factors for suicide.
They've identified some key predictors, but most of
these describe a person's long-term risk.
So the problem with the known risk factors for suicide,
and things like mental illness, is that
they apply to a huge percentage of the population,
and most of us are not at immediate risk of suicide.
The other issue is that they don't tend to change
very much from day to day,
whereas suicidal tendencies can.
Mental health professionals can ask patients
about their suicidal thoughts and plans directly,
but predicting a person's risk
still involves some guesswork.
Therapists can't monitor at risk people every moment,
but maybe smartphones can.
One research project called MAPS—
Mobile Assessment for the Prediction of Suicide—
aims to turn research about suicidal behavior
into a smartphone app that can predict spikes and risk.
The approach could be especially effective for young
people, whose social and emotional lives
are so wrapped up with their smartphones.
Suicide among teens is increasingly common—
it's the second leading cause of death
among young people in the U.S.
In a 2017 CDC survey of nearly 15,000 high
school students across the United States,
7.4 percent said they'd attempted
suicide in the last 12 months.
In the MAPS study, teams consent to let an
app on their smartphones collect data
around the clock.
They're relying on information from previous studies and
previous theories about suicide to tell
them where to look.
By analyzing the language teens type,
their tone of voice, and their facial expressions,
the researchers will look for signs of psychological pain
that might increase their risk of suicide a
A phone's activity tracking functions
can reveal disruptions in a person's sleep habit,
such as insomnia, which has been associated with
suicide in adolescents.
Finally, MAPS will look for signs of
faltering social relationships, rejection, and bullying.
They'll track how frequently a person
reaches out to their online contacts,
how diverse those contacts are,
and how often the communication is reciprocated.
One thing that clinicians have observed
about suicidal impulses, is that they're ephemeral.
They tend to pass;
they fluctuate and spike, and then they go away.
And so the idea with this app is that
if it could predict when you're in trouble,
or when you're about to be in trouble,
it could actually step in, and it could suggest
a coping strategy for you,
it could encourage you to reach out to
your therapist, or if you wanted to set it
up this way, it could also contact that person directly.
This research is still preliminary.
We don't know yet whether the predictions
from phone data will be accurate,
but tracing our digital footprints could
someday be a tool to guide people
when suicidal impulses are strong—
and ultimately save lives.